speaking of Wars the military is now
doing this thing that it's done many
times before recruitment in the military
is off nobody wants to join the military
right now because everybody is kind of
sniffed out what's going on nobody
really believes
like anything
that the government says about why the
military does anything it does so what
tends to happen is when you have this
like Crisis you basically have a ton of
young people now that go you know
I'll do other things I'll get into
crypto
uh I'll figure it out I'll build a
YouTube channel I don't know but nobody
wants to uh be in the military anymore
so the military is now claiming that it
is woke
it is too woke this is what the the
response is that's why nobody wants to
join it's not because we've seen
Afghanistan and Iraq and all of these
things and everybody is fed up it's
because the military apparently is too
woke meaning that when you join it I
don't know what happens they cut your
dick off
or so the Army missed its recruiting
goal by about 15 000 new soldiers in
2022 coming up about 25 short of his
goal at a time when each of the services
was struggling to meet their benchmarks
military officials worry that half that
all of the branches have had to reach
deep into their pools of delayed entry
applicants which we know who that is
right it's you know these are the people
that really don't need to be in it they
don't add much these are the people who
we go yeah we'll let you in depending on
how bad things get but for now go home
like if you show up to the recruitment
with your own battle plan drawn out that
involves your own town they go you go
back home keep doing stuff in the yard
do some sit-ups and push-ups in the yard
and we'll get you back when we need it
so the delayed entry applicants are like
cops that I guess have been thrown out
of the police force for shooting uh
black people and you know just the
people that show up and they you don't
want to take them right away you go you
guys just maybe they have medical things
you know I've I have seizures I've been
you go whatever so now we're we're gonna
have to start using that military
recruiters have leaned on tried and true
factors to explain the challenges
including low unemployment and a dearth
of applicants up to physical educational
and behavioral standards because
remember to join our military you have
to be a brilliant
good person who's never had any
behavioral problems but the truth is I
love this article and this is from
military times because I get it they're
trying to you know this is okay but the
truth is no one keeps detailed data on
what stopping America's youth from
signing up yeah
I I think people have it's called 19
fake Wars
experts and Senior military leaders
point to The Perennial factors of
competition from the private sector and
a dwindling number of Young Americans
both qualified and interested in
military service but what they don't
have too much information on is why the
propensity is going down and whether the
country is undergoing an ideological
shift towards military service one
possibility this is Senator Tommy
tuberville a republican from Alabama
Tommy tuberville has figured it out
the military is too woke
and apparently people that want to go
die in foreign countries don't want to
be woke and they're afraid that if they
join the military instead of being
immediately sent to their death they'll
be made to read literature about trans
people I don't know so Tommy tuberville
says uh the military is too woke for
example
uh the Republican from Alabama I believe
maybe Alaska I think it's Alabama for
example is among a group of Republican
Senators who have repeatedly blamed
recruiting problems on the Biden
Administration for trying to build a
woke Army
uh the director of the National Defense
at the Heritage Foundation a
conservative think tank recently upon
that wokeness is the quote Chief worry
of grizzled American veterans today is
that true
could that
could that could that possibly be true
listen to the word
wokeness is the quote Chief worry of
grizzled American veterans today
you know
how many people get back from these wars
and kill themselves because they don't
have like you know like mental health
care they have suffering from PTSD they
can't be employed because they try to
get a job as a security guard at
McDonald's but they're trained in the
military so no matter what happens they
start being overly aggressive like
grabbing people and they're like whoa
calm down like you know but their Chief
problem
suicide not it drug and alcohol abuse
not at the chief problem if you are a
grizzled American Veteran I love the
word grizzled
grizzled American veterans meaning
people who've seen and done things it's
like that haunt them
there and their main wokeness is the
main problem
quote the largest threat they see by far
to our current military is the weakening
of its fabric by radical Progressive or
woke policies being imposed not by a
rising generation of slackers but by the
very leaders charged with ensuring their
Readiness wokeness in the military is
being imposed by elected and appointed
leaders in the Y and I don't even by the
way what is the wokeness in like
does this go dead does it say anything
about what the wokeness is
what is the wokeness like if you join
like how gay has the military gotten
like I I haven't been paying attention
but like how woke
is okay in reality service members spend
hundreds of hours a year on mandatory
training covering everything from
operational safety to financial
responsibility and suicide and sexual
assault prevention with a tiny fraction
of that focusing on diversity equity and
inclusion education so I'm wondering
what exactly in the military is super
well I know that they're bringing in new
programs I guess but what is like I I
think one of them is just like let's
keep the assault down because there's a
lot of sexual assault so like just keep
it
they're cutting back on rape
yeah well that's woke but I think that I
don't know is it
are they doing like drag shows in the
middle like is that do they do drag
queen Story Hour in Barracks like do
these guys have to sit through I'm
trying to think in my head Wonder like
what exactly the woke military is I
could be wrong by the way if you're in
the military let me know that I could be
tell me what happened tell me what's so
he offended you that was going on in the
middle I don't know here's a wait hold
on this is a picture of a woman this
might be getting it here's a picture of
a woman she's on the ground she's
wearing a covered mask okay this is
heading in the woke direct maybe I'm
wrong this is the point in the show
where I go perhaps I'm wrong a U.S
military academy uh Cadet practices
physical training at the Army Combat
fitness test during Cadet basic training
at West Point okay so it's a woman it's
a picture of a woman and she's okay
um
but what seems to incense people is that
the issue of racial disparities
discussed at all not that it's truly
cutting into time spent on train so I
guess they're doing some more like the
race classes
when Marine Corps Reserve Conor Colonel
Matthew F amadon Director of Veterans
and military families at the George W
bush Institute well he did a lot for the
confidence in the military wrote A
Commentary arguing that veterans
veterans to help during the recruiting
crisis process by recommending military
service to their kids and other young
people
military times was inundated with
hundreds of emails from veterans saying
they would do no such thing
their reasons are varied but most said
wokeness is to blame
their reasons are varied many of the
people we sent to kill uh people in the
fake war that we didn't really pay and
they won't have their kids and grandkids
do it and their reasons are varied but
most said wokeness
interesting they accuse the military of
becoming too political or a social
experiment
I'll be blunt I wouldn't encourage
anyone to join today's armed forces and
I discouraged both of my sons from
considering serving wrote Peter Dimas
who described himself as a third party
generation veteran quote America's
military leaders have been sold out sold
out the services for their own
advancement and reflect all the poorest
qualities of Civilian leadership
but what is going on can you find
anything about like an example of like
the military going crazy
with wokeness because
with awoke military because because
there's something there is something
here something's going on oh you know I
I think they're overblowing it
but there's something that this is based
on and I just can't
I don't know what it is I know there's
women in the military there's gay people
in the military there's trans people in
the military
so we know that
but I'm wondering what exactly is so
over the top maybe they're just teaching
these annoying classes
and it's like you should have a cohesive
unit you shouldn't have like this weird
equity and inclusion I don't even know
why they're you're all gonna die and
we're sending you to die and we don't
even really know why soon it's for you
Ukraine
so
with a woke military whose most senior
officers concerned about white rage he's
a little bit of a clown that guy I've
seen him he likes attention it's that
that's that General who's always like I
want to know why why he's like
auditioning for HBO Max like comedy
special he's like I want to know why
it's just this guy I forget his name but
he's a big General and he's very
critical uh and he's like I want to know
why white people hate I want to know why
my people hate and like they love him
the New York Times like everybody frames
him up on the cameras you're like he's
great
um
so here we go this is what they're
talking about
um
with the world militaries most senior
officers concerned about white rage
searching for a tattletail process is to
discover
and discharge while white extremists
they want to discharge white extremists
from the military blaming it on toxic
masculinity discharging real Warriors
for not getting vaccinated disagree with
that they should not have done that
that's so stupid
having a two-day standout to discuss
white extremism that seems in itself
extreme
the promotion and expansion of women in
combat yeah just put them in there see
what happens
some of them will be okay lowering
physical fitness standards to
accommodate naturally weaker women
well you know if you're gonna if you
wanna be in the military and you're a
woman
let let them in and yeah they're not
going to be able to do the same things
men do but they can kill they can kill
children
women can kill babies right I mean I
yeah I don't think it's a it's a problem
um recruiting with social justice and
diversity ads so I don't I don't know
listen
I get it I get it gets a little Annoying
if you're you sign up in the military
and you're like listen just let me at
least hear Let me just fight and die and
don't annoy me which I agree with like
stop with the diversity inclusion like
everybody in the military is the same
they've all joined
many of them didn't have other options
that there they don't have to you don't
have to divide them along the lines of
race or
sex or whatever you're doing just just
let them all go and fight in the Ukraine
they don't have to
I don't know pregnant women are going to
fight our Wars It's a mockery of the US
Military
who said that Tucker
Tucker calls and said that